this is an eight news now breaking news
alert
making it for a vacant clubhouse and a
north valley gated community goes up in
flames that fire started earlier this
afternoon crews remain on scene good
afternoon thanks for joining us i'm
kirsten joyce and i'm christian casa as
well this is at the silverstone golf
course just east of floyd lamb state
park let's get right out to sasha loftis
with an update
kiersten and christian there are flames
still shooting out of this building over
three hours after it started you can see
firefighters hard at work but these
flames just keep coming back keep
reigniting now firefighters tell us this
started just after 12 30 this afternoon
here at this vacant clubhouse you can
see again the flames shooting out of the
building here this video was from
earlier no one was hurt but this
building and golf course have been
vacant for more than five years we spoke
with some neighbors in the area who say
it's caused issues in the community for
a while now
there's been quite a few issues in the
past i know that there have been
squatters and homeless people that have
stayed there we've even seen some of the
local high school kids come during their
lunch hour so there's lots of in and out
movement but of course no one lives
there so we don't know who they are
now las vegas fire and rescue is still
calling this quote a heavy fire per
their last update around 3 30 and that's
pretty easy to see here back out live if
you look at the scene now north las
vegas fire is also helping with this
operation as firefighters work hard to
get this under control as they have been
for the past two hours we do see a lot
of people in this community in this
neighborhood just really coming out to
watch this again luckily no one was hurt
but this should stay continue rather for
a while longer so stay with eight news
now for updates on air and online
reporting live tonight sasha loftis live
local now